hallo deutsch schule punkt ch hören und
nachsprechen lektion 42 hört zu und
spricht nach
wo ist mein handy
es ist hier es ist hier
wo ist meine tasche wo ist meine tasche
sie ist dort sie ist dort wo ist mein
ziel
wo ist mein ziel
er hängt dort am kleider
ende er hängt dort am kleiderständer
wo sind meine deutsch bücher wo sind
meine deutsch bücher
sie liegen hier auf dem tisch sie liegen
hier auf dem tisch
ich telefoniere mit meiner mutter
ich telefon
ihre mit meiner mutter
ich telefoniere
meinem vater
ich telefoniere mit meinem vater
ich telefoniere mit meinen eltern
ich habe mit
einer frau telefoniert
ich habe
meiner frau telefoniert
ich rufe meine mutter an
ich rufe meinen
ich rufe meinen vater an
ich rufe meine eltern an ich rufe meine
eltern an
hast du deine zähne geputzt
ja
meine zähne geputzt
ja ich
habt ihr eure zähne geputzt
ja
haben unsere zähne geputzt
unsere zähne geputzt
hast du deine hausaufgaben gemacht hast
du deine haut
aufgaben gemacht
ja ich habe meine hausaufgaben gemacht
habt ihr eure hausaufgaben gemacht
ja wir haben unsere hausaufgaben gemacht
ja wie
haben unsere hausaufgaben gemacht
hast du dein zimmer aufgeräumt
nein ich habe mein zimmer nicht
aufgeräumt
nein ich habe mal
zimmer nicht aufgeräumt
habt ihr euer zimmer aufgeräumt
nein wir haben
zimmer nicht aufgeräumt
nein wir haben unser zimmer nicht
aufgeräumt
hast du deinen koffer gepackt hast du
deinen koffer gepackt
nein ich habe meinen koffer nicht
gepackt
habt ihr euren koffer gepackt
nein
unseren koffer nicht gepackt
nein wir haben unseren koffer nicht
gepackt
hast du deine katze gefüttert
ja ich habe meine katze gefüttert
habt
katze gefüttert
habt ihr eure
top
ja wir haben unsere katze gefüttert
paul zieht seinen pullover an
er trägt seinen pullover er trägt seinen
pullover
thoma
eine neue freundin
thomas
kennst du seine neue freundin
martin hat ein
schönes zelt
martin hat ein schönes zelt
ich habe letztes jahr sein zelt
ausgeliehen
hast du die
dann von luca kennengelernt
hast du die eltern von luca
kennengelernt
nein
seine eltern nicht kennen gelernt
nein ich habe seine eltern nicht kennen
gelernt
monika zitieren pullover an
sie trägt ihren pullover sie trägt ihren
pullover
heidi hat einen neuen freund
kennst du ihren neuen
freund
kennst du ihren neuen freund
ruth hat
u
vehlow
ich habe ihr velo gestern ausgeliehen
ich habe
lok gestern ausgeliehen
hast du die eltern von maria
kennengelernt
nein
nicht kennengelernt
nein ich habe ihre eltern nicht kennen
gelernt